bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat dans moins de quinze minutes vous
aurez en direct sur notre antenne les
traditionnelles questions d'actualité en
direct entre acteurs action entre les
ministres bien sûr et les sénateurs le
premier ministre jean-marc ayrault sera
là pour répondre aux nombreuses
questions qui se posent sur le chômage
bien sûr la ministre de la justice
aussi sera présente et avec nous une
autre ministre qui nous fait le plaisir
de venir sur notre antenne pour discuter
un petit peu de toute son actualité mais
aussi répondre aux nombreuses questions
d'actualité avec nous nicole bricq la
ministre du commerce extérieur bonjour
madame avec le micro ça sera peut-être
un petit peu plus simple alors je
voudrais qu'on parle évidemment de tous
vos sujets qui vous intéressent
on va aborder ça dans la longueur mais
d'abord peut-être quelques questions
immédiates sur l'actualité ce soir le
président de la république va s'exprimer
à la télévision
que peut-il annoncé que peut-il dire le
président de la république a choisi en
ce moment difficile pour les français de
s'adresser directement à eux
donc c'est ce soir qu'il va reprendre
sans doute tout la politique et
notamment la politique économique qui a
été mise en place par lui et son
gouvernement auquel j'ai l'honneur
d'appartenir j'ai toute confiance dans
ses capacités pédagogiques
c'est dans un moment difficile où il
faut dire aux français qu' ils sont bons
collectivement et individuellement et
que nous sommes dans une période
délicate en europe
moi qui voyage dans le monde bouge et
dire exactement ce qui se passe
la question qu'on me pose faut jamais
l'oublier c'est comment va l'europe car
nous savons pourtant fait et donc
après on nous dit que ce soit les
autorités ou les entreprises étrangères
comment va la france dans l'europe
toujours ne jamais oublier l'horizon qui
est le nôtre et nicole bricq est ce que
vous diriez toujours pour prolonger
cette question que ce soit c'est le
tournant du quinquennat pour le
président ou est ce que c'est un
exercice de routine tout simplement
non je crois que ce n'est ni l'un ni
l'autre c'est toujours important quand
le président de la république s'adresse
aux français et aux françaises
directement qu'il leur parle qui leur
parlent de leurs difficultés mais qui
leur parle aussi de leur capacité à
rebondir
moi qui vois beaucoup d'entreprises en
région et à l'étranger je sais que les
français sont capables de rebondir de
réagir et d'être aussi dans la
mondialisation et je crois que la france
va trouver sa place dans la
mondialisation
c'est normal dans des périodes
difficiles où le chômage monte
régulièrement et je sais l'impact
terrible car c'est le chômage parce
qu'il frappe tout le monde de près ou de
loin il peut ruiner la confiance c'est
pour ça que le président moi je le
soutiens totalement quand ils fixent un
objectif de stabiliser le chômage est de
faire retourner cette courbe infernale
parce que je sais que la confiance ça
rythme avec la croissance
et ça rime aussi avec confiance parce
que là ce que peut être ce qu ont besoin
les français c'est peut-être ce message
que va apporter le président sociaux
c'est un message de confiance vous
diriez qu'il y ait un sentiment de
pessimisme en france on sent même les
ministres un petit peu pessimiste c'est
vrai à m'écouter moi je fais pas partie
de ceux qui sont pessimistes julien est
le meilleur compliment qu'on me fait
c'est vous vous nous donner une énergie
positive
donc j'espère la donner à vos
téléspectateurs
mais vous le sentez vous qui voyagez qui
voyez de nombreuses entreprises et des
entreprises étrangères
vous sentez qu'en france il ya ce
pessimisme que les étrangers nous
regardent avec vous faites toujours la
tête il ya toujours des premiers jeux
d'éveil à un de vos confrères de la
presse écrite qui en ce début d'année a
fait ce qu elle fait régulièrement un
sondage
européens et que répondent les français
à la première question est ce que vous
êtes inquiet de cette de ceux de cette
mondialisation ils répondent à
majoritairement non et quand on leur
pose une autre question est-ce que vous
pensez que la france peut tirer parti de
cette mondialisation
ils répondent à la verse ils sont
inquiets c'est là où leur pessimisme et
je pense que la france doit les français
doivent croire en eux et le message que
porte le président de la république
c'est un message de confiance de
responsabilité il faut que tous les
ministres moi c'est pas pour moi le
message je vois le président comme tous
mes collègues tous les mercredis au
conseil des ministres et nous dit ça y
est vous avez réfléchi vous avez défini
votre stratégie
maintenant vous tendez toutes vos forces
vers l'action de manière à ce que la
cohérence de notre politique économique
porte ses fruits
alors on est dans un moment difficile en
france et en europe
il faut tenir bon et passer ce cap des
tempêtes et je suis persuadé que les
français sont capables de le faire ils
ont montré dans leur histoire ça c'est
pour les côtés français nicole bricq
côté international comment est-ce qu'on
réagit quand on voit l'état de la france
finalement le niveau de chômage
c'était cette espèce de crise sociale et
crise morale qui s'abat sur nous mais à
l'étranger comme toujours
est ce que les dirigeants turcs ont
finalement bah écoutez quand je regarde
les chiffres je défends beaucoup
l'attractivité de notre territoire nous
sommes le premier pays en europe à
accueillir les investissements étrangers
dans des centres productif c'est à dire
dans des usines dans des entreprises qui
produisent en france avec une main
d'oeuvre française et qui exportent à
partir de la france et c'est très
important pour moi parce que j'ai reçu
un objectif du premier ministre
d'arriver au bout du quinquennat avoir
une balance équilibrée
hors énergie
donc je dis aux sera pas simple venez
investir mais je constate qu'elles le
font toujours parce que nous avons des
dispositifs de fiscalité attractif le
crédit impôt recherche est maintenant le
crédit impôt compétitivité emploi
croissance qui est fait pour toutes les
entreprises qu'elles soient françaises
et étrangères
et je sais que on loue la qualité de la
main d'oeuvre française dans ces
entreprises
donc pour l'instant nous sommes
attractifs il faut le rester on est pas
tous seuls en europe la concurrence est
vive
est ce qu'il ya des exemples très
concrets de france attractive alors
qu'on sait très bien qu'il ya des usines
qui ferment quand on parle de
pneumatiques d'automobiles
les secteurs qui fonctionne ce sont
l'aéronautique mais quoi d'autre part
non mais y'a pas que l'aéronautique mais
nous avons des entreprises qui se
battent dans la famille santé moi j'ai
une famille de produits et de services
qui est la famille mieux se soigner
c'est porteur en europe c'est porteur
dans le monde
dans l'agroalimentaire nous avons non
seulement des navires amiraux mais nous
avons beaucoup d'entreprises qui se
porte à l'exportation il ya une règle
c'est que lorsqu'on innove et bien on
exporte et on se porte bien
donc il faut vraiment que le moteur
investissements se retrouve au rendez
vous l'état fait son travail au travers
des désinvestissements qu'il met par les
deniers publics les collectivités aussi
les régions je m'appuie beaucoup sur les
régions quelles sont mes pilotes à
l'export et les finances des fonds nous
avons nous commerce extérieur ouvert un
fonds de fonds de 150 millions au
travers des investissements d'avenir
pour aider les entreprises à tenir le
coup à l'international on a mis des
dispositifs en place
j'ai parlé du crédit impôt compétitivité
il faudrait aussi parler on le dit
jamais assez la france est capable de se
réformer
quand vous voyez l'accord
interprofessionnel qui est intervenu
entre partenaires sociaux qui donne plus
de souplesse aux entreprises et plus de
sécurité professionnelle
aux salariés c'est un élément fort
d'attractivité on nous parle toujours
des allemands confédération poser la
question exactement sur l'exportation
j'accepte la comparaison et je ne rougis
pas de la comparaison
je sais qu'on a des problèmes de
compétitivité mais en même temps je sais
aussi que l'allemagne s'est pas
forcément le modèle idéal je la prends
en pièces détachées j'ai l'habitude de
le dire et la force de négociation
qu'ils ont dans leur entreprise est un
atout de compétitivité
donc nous on le met en oeuvre ça va
passer dans la loi très bientôt mon
collègue sapin après sa pause mais c'est
très important notamment c'est très
important parce que ça lui en sécurité
parcours professionnel et en même temps
ça de sadi aux entreprises
oui vous avez plus de souplesse
maintenant que faites vous de tout ce
que le gouvernement mais comme cadre à
votre disposition
comment faites vous pour faire repartir
l'investissement privé alors que nous
avons mis un denier public
donc ça c'est très important et il faut
que tout le monde s'y met et que tout le
monde là où il est
croit en ses capacités à surmonter cette
crise les conneries qu'on sait très bien
qu'au bout de 10 mois que vous êtes à la
tête de l'état et donc au gouvernement
et est toujours difficile de faire un
premier bilan mais vous diriez que tout
est sur la table aujourd'hui les outils
sont là mais que c'est une machine très
l'autre finalement m'écoutais je m'en
aperçois j'étais avec le premier
ministre la semaine dernière pour parler
du pacte de compétitivité et pour parler
du dispositif à l'exportation nous
étions à angers ensemble dans le
maine-et-loire et nous avons vu des
chefs d'entreprise nous avons vu des
jeunes volontaires internationaux en
entreprises qui sont l'image de la
france à l'exportation nous avons vu
bien sûr les autorités publiques région
collectivité et nous voyons bien qu'il
faut faire cet effort pédagogique
ce n'est pas parce qu'on décide une
chose fût ce par la loi qu'elles
diffusent dans la société française donc
chaque ministre il doit faire ce que
nous avons fait avec le premier nice la
semaine dernière
allez faire cette pédagogie et je crois
que le plus grand pédagogue parmi nous
c'est quand même le président de la
république et on va voir ce soir ils
doivent certainement aussi de parler de
ce qu'on appelle la map cette
modernisation de l'action publique vous
aussi vous allez être chargé par le
premier j'ai reçu ma fille donne tous
les ministres vous avez une feuille de
route alors vous connaissez les cas la
méthode de héros on évalue et on agit en
fonction de cette évaluation donc je
suis chargé j'ai mis un pain de
l'évaluation concernant tout le
dispositif français à l'export parce que
là aussi on nous parle beaucoup des
allemands on nous dit à mes yeux ils
chassent en meute
ils sont bien organisés donc que dis-je
que dis-je à tous les services français
à l'étranger et ça c'est de la
diplomatie économique de terrain
présentez-vous de manière groupée
ayez une bannière française et c'est
pour ça qu'avec mon collègue menteuse
bourg pèlerins et madame pinel
nous avons lancé aussi la mission marque
france le made in france dans le nord
que c'est une grand nombre elles ou tous
ceux qui sont français qui exportent ou
qui veulent le faire puissent peuvent se
retrouver
parce que nous avons une touche
française nous avons une capacité
d'innovation
nous avons un petit défaut nous sommes
un peu ami divy de la lys ça peut être
une qualité mais c'est souvent il faut
qu'au port de commerce
il vaut mieux être regroupées c'est ce
que je m'efforce de faire dans mes
familles prioritaires à l'export et
fabrique cette semaine il y avait aussi
un dossier très important pour vous
c'est ce projet d'accord de partenariat
de commerce entre la l'autre l'europe et
les états unis où est-ce qu'on donnait
aujourd'hui concrètement et bien on en
est que la commission européenne qui est
compétente va nous demander à nous les
états membres les 27 de lui donner un
mandat de négociation
donc j'ai consulté toutes les
entreprises françaises je rencontrerai
les syndicats organisée au niveau
européen la crs pour avoir leur point de
vue les entreprises françaises m'ont
donné globalement un avis favorable mais
j'ai dit publiquement lundi et je le
redis aujourd'hui que nous avons des
lignes rouges et notamment nous ne
voulons pas c'est quoi ces conceptions
culturelles soit dans la négociation
nous y tenons en europe depuis les
années 90 et nous ne voulons pas que ça
fasse partie du mandat de négociation et
nous avons les intérêts offensifs à
défendre je serai aux etats-unis au mois
d'avril
vous allez m'écoute vérifier mais pour
vérifier la volonté des congressmen
américains d'aller dans cet accord
ce qu'ils en attendent et nous avons à y
gagner parce que l'amérique est en
croissance alors que nous nous peinons
au niveau européen à des niveaux de
croissance trop fait nous y avons un
intérêt mais en même temps il faut qu'on
soit capable de se défendre
n'avons pas la même conception de la
propriété intellectuelle nous avons des
intérêts agricoles qui ne sont pas
concordants nous ne voulons pas de boeuf
aux hormones ou par exemple sur la
suppression des droits de douane
oui la méthode c'est ça c'est ce que je
sais très important il faut baisser les
droits de douane c'est ça le but d'un
accord de libre échange mais en même
temps ce qui est le plus important c'est
de baisser les réglementations qui nous
sont opposés pour nous empêcher nous
introduire sur le marché américain et
donc la discussion elle portera sur les
droits de douane mais c'est pas le plus
difficile le plus difficile c'est d'être
à armes égales avec les entreprises
américaines
c'est pour ça que j'ai proposé que on
négocie au fur à mesure que les
réglementations se rejoignent parce
qu'on ne peut pas accepter d'un grand
pays comme les etats-unis qu'il ait des
pratiques très protectionniste on dit
toujours qu'ils sont libres échangistes
et que nous les français on est un peu
il fait un petit peu leur leur part rien
aux produits européens par exemple du
classement il faut qu'ils les ouvre
davantage que ce qu'ils ne font ce n'est
qu'à ce prix là que nous aurons un
accord positif pour les industries
européennes pour nos industries d' si on
peut prendre un exemple pour eux parce
qu'après on va aller évidemment suivre
les questions d'actualité il ya des
produits français qui aujourd'hui sont
interdits de territoire aux bus ils sont
pas interdits mais ils ont des barrières
réglementaires tels par exemple les
marchés publics américains sont très peu
ouvert aux entreprises étrangères et le
plan de relance américain de 800
milliards nous laisse à nous européens
une toute petite petite portion par
exemple vous ne pouvez pas si vous
voulez faire des uniformes je parle pas
militaire y compris civile ils doivent
être tous américains
c'est pas normal un mois dernier mot
peut-être sur l'euro j'ai regardé le
court aujourd'hui c'est un euro 28 c'est
trop il a baissé il a baissé ses prix
baisser mais pas pour de bonnes raisons
parce que on sait bien qu'on a cette
crise chypriote qui n'est toujours pas
réglée qui reste là ça veut dire que
l'euro est un petit peu bousculé donc
faut pas qu'il soit trop mais en même
temps n'oublions jamais que la monnaie
c'est un outil il doit pas utilisée à
des fins compte de compétition
commerciale mais en même temps il faut
être très compétitive sur notre marché
pour pouvoir aller à l'exportation alors
vous l'avez vu sur cette image merci
beaucoup nicole bricq le président jean
pierre bel est en train d'arriver dans
l'hémicycle il est dans le couloir vous
voyez c'est cette traditionnelle image
quand vous propose en direct sur public
sénat nicole bricq on voulait se
retourner dans les musiques car
évidemment vous allez assister à cette
question d'actualité merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions et nous évidemment nous allons
suivre la séance de questions
d'actualité je voulais dit il ya
beaucoup de questions jean marc ayrault
est présent il va répondre à des
questions très importantes qui sont
liées notamment au chômage
madame taubira est là aussi pour
répondre aux questions sur un sens à
tout à l'heure pour on refait la serrure
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle et des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
je rappelle avec insistance encore une
fois que l'auteur de la question de même
que le ou la ministre pour sa réponse
disposent chacun de deux minutes trente
et pas plus la parole est à monsieur
claude bérit-debat pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'égalité des territoires et du logement
madame la ministre je tiens à saluer les
mesures annoncées par le président de la
république jeudi dernier dans le cadre
du plan d'investissement pour le
logement
elle témoigne de l'entière mobilisation
du président de la république du
gouvernement et de vous-mêmes madame la
ministre
et je tiens à vous en féliciter ce plan
répond à la fois une urgence sociale à
une urgence économique
ce n'est d'ailleurs pas un hasard si les
professionnels du bâtiment mais aussi
les bailleurs sociaux et l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés l'ont accueilli
favorablement la principale mesure de ce
plan la baisse de la tva à 5% pour la
construction et la réhabilitation de
logements sociaux étaient
particulièrement attendus elle s'inscrit
dans le cadre du pacte conclu avec le
monde hlm ce qui est une nouveauté
je rappelle d'ailleurs que la précédente
majorité avait relevé de 5 à 7 ce taux
de tva la majorité actuelle le ramène à
5%
cela devrait mécaniquement généré 22
mille cinq cents logements sociaux
supplémentaires
je tiens à saluer également les mesures
en matière de rénovation énergétique à
dimension à la fois sociales économiques
écologiques qui permettront de rénover
500 mille logements par an notamment
grâce à l'octroi d'une prime de 1350
euros par ménage
je ne saurais non plus passer sous
silence la volonté de lutter contre les
recours abusifs et contre l'inflation
des normes avec notamment un moratoire
de deux ans mesure
demandée depuis longtemps par le sénat
et sur les banques qui sont face à moi
au total je considère donc que ce plan
répond aux attentes actuaires pur
plusieurs raisons il pose d'abord des
objectifs clairs et précis il fixe
ensuite ce qui est nouveau
un cap ambitieux au service des français
il mobilise enfin tous les acteurs
privés publics
face à l'urgence sociale et à l'urgence
économique
il nous faut toutefois aller vite dès
lors madame la ministre
ma question est la suivante quels sont
les effets en termes de construction de
logements et d'emplois attendues avec ce
plan et puisqu'il faut aller vite
quels seront le contenu et le calendrier
des ordonnances que le gouvernement a
annoncé vouloir prendre dans ce domaine
je vous remercie
merci pour vous répondre dans la dame
cécile duflot ministre de l'egalité le
territoire et du logement
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur bérit-debat je dois vous dire
que ce travail qui est une deuxième
étape après des premières mesures
d'urgence prises très tôt dans le début
de cette mandature avec la mise en place
d'un dispositif d'incitation fiscale
avec une loi à voter sur la cession du
foncier public ainsi que l'augmentation
du pourcentage de logements sociaux
obligatoires dans les communes de plus
de 3500 habitants est un moment
important et un moment qui s'appuie
aussi sur le travail de nombreux
parlementaires je veux remercier le
président raúl de m'avoir invité hier
devant la commission des affaires
économiques où j'ai pu longuement
présenté les dispositions de ce plan
je voudrais indiquer pour répondre
précisément à votre question que les
objectifs que nous attendions dans son
double d'abord de faire face à une
situation extrêmement difficile des
professionnels du secteur situation qui
a permis à laquelle nous répondons par
une mobilisation en direction des
entreprises par le biais du système
d'auto liquidation de la tva et des
avances de trésorerie issu de la paix
pays mais aussi par et c'est l'élément
décisif du passage à 5% de la tva dans
le secteur du logement social
le lancement de nom
heureuse nouvelle opération tant de
réhabilitation que de construction dans
un secteur qui a les moyens de s'engager
dans ce travail et c'est pourquoi vous
l'avait indiqué dès la fin avant la fin
du mois de mai le premier ministre
signera avec l'union sociale pour
l'habitat
un pacte qui actera les en gaz les
engagements de l'union sociale après que
l'état et on l'a vu a pris les siens des
responsabilités qui sont importantes
puisque les objectifs de construction
fixé par le président de la république
sont élevées 500 mille nouveaux
logements par an cent cinquante mille
logements sociaux dans une période très
difficile mais dans une période où ces
objectifs sont nécessaires non seulement
pour l'activité du secteur mais surtout
pourrait répondre sur certains
territoires un criant besoin de
logements avec ce plan d'urgence avec le
travail structurel qui se fera dans le
cadre de la loi qui vous sera présenté
nous abordons les deux sujets
déverrouiller le secteur tout de suite
et lever un certain nombre de
difficultés et attaquer les difficultés
en profondeur sur la deuxième partie de
votre question et sur le calendrier
précis du travail que nous allons faire
sur cette question des normes de la
lutte contre les recours malveillants
souvent évoquée ici pour lequel nous
allons agir sur la transformation de
locaux de bureaux en logements
je pense pouvoir sous le contrôle du
ministre relations avec le parlement
pouvoir vous donner rendez-vous avant la
fin du mois de mai pour que la loi
d'habilitation qui nous permettra des
mesures effectives dès l'été soit votée
si vous le souhaitez merci
la parole est à notre collègue corinne
bouchoux pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
ait gardé sont chers collègues nous
aurions pu vous interroger par exemple
sur les chiffres du chômage et une des
solutions possibles à nos yeux la
transition énergétique
à l'instar de ce qu'ont choisi nos amis
allemands un autre sujet a retenu notre
attention
l'histoire ne se répète pas heureusement
mais il faut être capable d'en tirer des
enseignements
l'analyse des propos tenus ces dix
derniers jours dans la vie publique
française témoigne d'un ton et d'une
sémantique qui interroge ont deux ou
devrait nous interroger collectivement
nous tous à la peopolisation qui s'est
mise en place depuis des années est
exacerbée par la communication en temps
réel
s'ajoutent des petites phrases et
dérapages d'un genre nouveau qui ne
donne peut-être pas de notre vie
politique
une image très encourageante par
ailleurs et de surcroît contrairement
aux usages républicains et au principe
de séparation des pouvoirs
des jugements parfois sévères sont
publiquement un énoncé sur des
procédures judiciaires en cours ou des
décisions de justice rendues récemment
ou des procédures ouvertes une personne
mise en examen reste une personne
présumée innocente quel que soit son nom
et ses qualités actuelles ou passées on
nous parle par ailleurs aussi d'un juge
qui aurait reçu des menaces
ma question sera simple dans sa
formulation sans l'être dans sa mise en
oeuvre
car elle dépend de nous tous et toutes
collectivement chers collègues comment
faire en sorte que notre débat politique
reste d'une certaine tenue comme il le
fut ce matin sur la question de la
commémoration de la résistance
comment faire en sorte que nos
contradictions et nos affrontements même
vif reste reppublica faute de quoi mes
chers collègues si nous nous comportons
et je m'intègre dans cette autocritique
comme de mauvais amuseurs publics
nous aurons un jour à l'instar de ce qui
se passe en italie des taux d'abstention
record aux élections et l'entrée en
politique de nouveaux amuseurs publics
qui voudront nous copier et qui voudront
dénoncer les dérives constatées ces
dernières semaines je vous remercie
madame la ministre de nous dire comment
nous pourrons avoir ici à partir du 4
avril à l'occasion du débat sur le
mariage ouvert aux personnes de même
sexe un débat républicain où nos
divergences seront vives mais le débat
courtois et qui honore notre république
je vous remercie
merci madame christiane taubira garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice
ce président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice corinne bouchoux dans votre
question il y a deux aspects de la
parole publique qui lie à d'un côté les
petites phrases
est ce que vous appelez les dérapages
ces petites phrases qui effectivement
rétrécissent considérablement le débat
politique et affaiblissent
incontestablement la démocratie en tout
cas ne lui donne pas tout son lustre et
puis à d'un autre côté quelques propos
qui ont été tenus ces derniers jours à
l'occasion d'une décision judiciaire
nous sommes dans un état de droit si
d'ailleurs l'article 16 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme qui
vous le savez fait partie de notre bloc
de constitutionnalité qui prononce très
précisément que la séparation des
pouvoirs est un des principes fondateurs
de l'état de droit
cela suppose quelques règles parmi ces
règles il y a dans cette séparation des
pouvoirs une parole parlementaire qui ne
peut se porter inconsidérément sur
l'institution judiciaire
nous réitérons au nom du gouvernement le
respect du gouvernement vis-à-vis de
cette institution judiciaire qui l épine
dorsale de notre démocratie et qui est
animé par des femmes des hommes
extrêmement dévoués est totalement
conscient de la hauteur de la mission
qui leur est confiée je parle évidemment
des magistrats des magistrats
instructeurs mais de tous les magistrats
du siège
je parle des procureurs des procureurs
généraux je parle également des
greffiers et des fonctionnaires qui font
vivre l'oeuvre de justice nous avons
nous avons adressé évidemment à
l'ensemble des personnels judiciaires la
confiance du gouvernement et j'ai saisi
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
lundi pour l'interroger sur les
conséquences possibles sur le bon
fonctionnement de l'institution
judiciaire de ces propos et de
l'ambiance que provoquent ces propos
vous savez qu'un de ses magistrats a
reçu hier un courrier avec des munitions
à blanc et des menaces et que cela donne
le climat délétère dans lequel
se déroule à l'oeuvre de justice nous
avons je rappelais évidemment que si les
magistrats décidé d'agir en justice qui
disposerait qui pourraient bénéficier
bien sûr de la protection judiciaire qui
est prévu par leur donne ans de 1958 le
emmanuel levinas disait très clairement
que l'élection est un surplus
d'obligations pour lequel se profère le
jeu de la conscience morale je parlerais
plutôt de l'éthique mais l'idée est la
même c'est le niveau d'exigence et
j'espère que pour les prochains débats à
venir
mais pour tous les débats en général la
parole publique se portera responsable à
la hauteur de cette conscience éthique
merci la parole à madame isabelle
pasquet pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues l'économie chypriote déjà
ébranlée par la crise grecque est
aujourd'hui frappé au coeur aujourd'hui
semblant découvrir les caractéristiques
de ce paradis fiscal en pleine zone euro
vous qualifiez l'économie chypriote
d'économie casino mais monsieur le
ministre en date il attendre que toutes
les économies soient mises en état de
faillite les unes après les autres
du fait des incohérences des marchés qui
n'ont pour seul objectif que
l'enrichissement des plus fortunés pour
enfin déclarer la guerre à celui que
françois hollande qualifié dès 2100
visage le monde de la finance vous
parler d'économie de casino en faisant
référence aux avoirs bancaires chypriote
qui représente huit fois le pib de ce
pays
mais ce que vous ne dites pas c'est que
l'actif du bilan de bnp paribas est
lui-même égal au pib de la france
qu'attend-t-on pour que ces richesses
phénoménal soit réellement mise en
service de la croissance en allant bien
au delà des mesures que vous portez en
ce moment au parlement qui ne vise qu'à
contrôler en france 3 ou 4% des capitaux
concernés
lille va connaître cette ville 5 à 10%
de récession cette année et son taux de
chômage passera de 4 à 20%
cette action de l'eurogroupe qui a
choqué les peuples européens serait
pourtant un modèle à suivre selon son
président en irlande
et quand monsieur le ministre allez vous
au nom de la france faire entendre en
europe une autre voie que celle qui
consiste chaque fois qu'un pays est en
difficulté à s'accorder sur les seules
exigences d'austérité des dirigeants
allemands
s'il faut nettoyer les écuries d'augias
du secteur bancaire européen il faut le
faire partout
allez vous porter par exemple monsieur
le ministre à leurs groupes auxquels
vous participez l'exigence des sna
cynisme en du marché bancaire du
luxembourg dans l'opacité la puissance
et l'ultralibéralisme n'ont rien à
envier à celui de chypre
confirmez-vous ce que j'ai pu lire dans
la presse c'est à dire votre désaccord
avec l'initiative de l'europe à l'égard
de chypre admettez-vous enfin le
terrible déni de démocratie qui confine
maintenant à la caricature que
représente ce conseil des ministres
européens qui du jour au lendemain au
lendemain décide de mettre à genoux tout
un pays
l'europe est une grande idée il faut la
défendre oui mais contre qui contre les
prédateurs de la finance est pas en
assommant les populations merci merci
monsieur pierre moscovici ministre de
l'économie et des finances merci
monsieur monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
merci madame la sénatrice parce que je
voudrais d'abord vous dire une chose
simple c'est qu'il n'est pas question
d'évoquer chypre comme un modèle en quoi
que ce soit ni un modèle de problème ni
un modèle de solution
je comprends que vous soyez comme moi
d'ailleurs préoccupé par la situation de
l'économie chypriote et parce qu'il va
advenir à la population de chypre mais
soyez conscients en même temps qu'il y
avait là un modèle que j'ai appelé
d'économie casino on pourrait dire
autrement une plateforme financière
offshore qu'il était un possible de
défendre et vous n'allez pas vous
spécialement défendre une économie où le
système bancaire représente 7 à 8 fois
le pib
vous n'allez pas et vous spécialement
défendre une économie où les dépôts sont
rémunérés à 5 ou 6%
vous n'allez pas et vous spécialement
défendre une économie où les
non-résidents représentaient 45% des
dépôts vous n'aurez pas défendre une
économie où le blanchiment pouvait être
soupçonnée d'être la règle et vous
n'allez pas défendre une économie où le
taux de l'impôt sur les sociétés était à
10%
il y avait là un modèle économique qu'il
fallait remettre sur pied et c'est ce
que nous avons fait nous devions le
faire mais tout ça est exceptionnelle et
c'est pour cela que je ne partage pas et
d'ailleurs le président de l'eurogroupe
a corrigé l'idée selon laquelle il y
aurait un modèle de résolution
nous devions agir nous l'avons fait en
demandant que le système bancaire soit
restructurée et en faisant en sorte et
ça a été constamment constamment et je
vous le confirme puisque vous
m'interrogez la voix de la france celle
que j'ai portée avant pendant et a
fortiori après constamment disant qu'il
était hors de question que nous
n'approuvons pas l'idée que les
déposants qui élevait des dépôts
inférieure à cent mille euros soit
impliqué parce que le principe de la
garantie des dépôts dans la zone euro
comme l'a dit le président de la
république ya deux jours est un principe
intangible et qui doit s'appliquer à
tous
après l'air tout ça il ya la question
que vous soulevez de la démocratie
européenne l'eurogroupe n'impose pas
leurs groupes discutent etc les
autorités chypriotes qui était en face
de nous et ce sont elles qui ont voté
les textes qui étaient nécessaires
nous devons aussi respecter la
souveraineté par tous quel que soit le
peuple concerné quel que soit le peuple
dans l'euro pour le reste il nous reste
encore beaucoup à faire et c'est la
leçon que j'en tire
pour aller vers une véritable union
bancaire pour une europe de la
croissance pour faire en sorte que nous
redonnions des perspectives aux
européens pour équilibrer nos politiques
entre d'une part la réduction des
déficits qui est indispensable et
d'autre part la recherche de la
croissance qui est la condition même de
la reprise de l'emploi et puis de la
reprise de la prospérité il faudra à
l'égard de la population chypriote faire
preuve de solidarité
mais il était nécessaire je vous la
sueur d'agir et après une première
tentative dont je reconnais volontiers
que ce n'était pas la plus heureuse
nous avons fait la bonne décision car
les justes et elle est globale merci la
parole est à ce jean pierre chevènement
pour le groupe airness oui ma question
s'adresse également à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur j selb le monsieur le ministre
président de l'eurogroupe a proposé le
16 mars dernier de faire payer tous les
déposants des banques chypriotes
cette proposition adoptée à l'unanimité
par les différents pays membres de la
zone euro a dû être retirée parce
qu'elle portait atteinte notamment à la
garantie des dépôts inférieure à cent
mille euros
une seconde décision a dû être prise
exempt temps les comptes inférieurs à
100 mille euros mais non moins
arbitraire pour le reste imposant par
exemple à chypre une profonde
restructuration bancaire et en
particulier la fermeture de sa seconde
banque la banque like i des pertes à
égal à 30% ont été imposées aux autres
déposants monsieur j celle blom a
déclaré au monde je cite ceux qui ont
pris des risques doivent en assumer la
responsabilité
les déposants les actionnaires les
créanciers obligataires des banques
doivent être associés à leur
restructuration
ce message a un sens ou alors je ne
comprends plus rien c'est que les pays
les plus riches de la zone euro veut
limiter la contribution du mécanisme
européen de stabilité
vous nous avez dit monsieur le ministre
chypre était un cas exceptionnel à
l'instant même
mais ce qui a été fait pour chypre
monsieur miss ne pourrait-il pas inspiré
le traitement appliqué à d'autres pays
ceux par exemple qui à travers une
fiscalité anormalement basses joue le
rôle de paradis fiscal au sein de la
zone euro
et peut-être d'autres encore le risque
de fuite des capitaux
n'at-il pas été sous-estimée ma première
question c'est jusqu'où leur groupe
peut-il imposer impayés le changement de
son modèle économique
vous nous avez dit l'eurogroupe respecte
la souveraineté de chypre mais j'observe
que le président de la bce
monsieur draghi a menacé chypre si un
nouvel accord n'intervenait pas avant
lundi 25 mars au soir de couper le
robinet à liquidités destinées aux
banques chypriotes
on peut dire que la bce a utilisé la
grosse bertha pour faire plier chypre
que se serait-il passé si chypre avait
refusé la bce ne s'arroge t'elle pas
ainsi le droit d'expulser un état de la
zone euro c'est ma deuxième question est
ce que cette pratique est conforme aux
traités et surtout à l'esprit des
traités avec le contrôle des mouvements
de capitaux est ce que nous n'allons pas
vers un euro à plusieurs vitesses enfin
la dernière question concerne la russie
qui utilise chypre n'ont pas seulement
pour des fonds offshore mais également
pour le transit d'un certain nombre de
ces entreprises comme aeroflot est ce
qu'il y à un dialogue entre les
institutions européennes et la russie
est-ce que vous pouvez nous répondre là
dessus
monsieur le ministre merci mon cher
collègue la parole et à monsieur pierre
moscovici ministre l'économie et des
finances
votre question est à plusieurs
dimensions plusieurs ressorts d'abord je
répète ici qu'en effet la situation de
chypre est une situation exceptionnelle
et qu'elle ne pouvait être en rien un
exemple et je vous assure que sans qu'il
soit question à la place des peuples de
remettre en cause leurs propres modèles
celui ci était bancale et menaçait de
s'effondrer
la vérité c'est que leur groupe n'est
pas intervenu par hasard ou par plaisir
ou à n'importe quel moment
il est intervenu alors que ce système
que je viens de décrire il ya quelques
secondes était sur le point de faire
défaut de faire faillite
et s'il y avait eu des faux ou faillite
alors pour le coût pour l'économie
chypriote pour le peuple chypriote pour
les finances publique chypriote et pour
les banques chypriotes c'eût été un
cataclysme
mais j'ajoute que pour la zone euro
serait un choc peut être fatale et donc
nous devions agir encore une fois pas
par plaisir
deuxièmement cette action n'est pas une
action qui se déroule dans l'arbitraire
leur groupe c la réunion des 17
ministres de l'économie et des finances
de la zone euro y compris celui de
chypre en présence du fonds monétaire
international qui apporte son écot de la
banque centrale européenne qui est
présente de la commission européenne et
la discussion portait non pas sur
quelque chose que nous imposions mai sur
un programme
d'ailleurs c'est tellement vrai qu'en
vérité le premier raccord peu qu'ils
n'étaient pas suffisamment solide qui
comportait certaines lacunes ou certains
défauts à commencer par le fait de
toucher les déposants en dessous de 100
mille euros
cet accord est de fait été refusée par
le parlement chypriote et par le
président chypriote et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous sommes revenus la
semaine suivante pour construire un
accord qui lui et je crois plus
équilibré il est vrai qu'il fallait
restructurer le secteur bancaire tout
simplement parce qu'il n'était pas
viable
quant à la banque centrale européenne en
l'occurrence je considère qu'il était
dans son rôle parce que nous apportons
des liquidités la banque centrale
européenne c'est nous mêmes
et quand on sollicite le mécanisme
européen de stabilité
ce sont en vérité nos finances publiques
qui sont concernés puisque nous sommes
actionnaire à 20% et il faudra
d'ailleurs que le moment venu nous
apportions cette contribution faire plus
n'aurait pas été justifiée parce que il
y avait effectivement des
responsabilités
ce défaut du système bancaire à cette
mauvaise gestion du système bancaire à
cette hypertrophie du système bancaire
je considère donc qu'il ya eu sans doute
une sous-estimation lors de la première
réunion de leur groupe et je l'avais
signalé du risque que cela soit compris
comme une menace à la garantie des
dépôts et que ensuite nous sommes
revenus en accord avec les autorités
chypriotes
avec la solution la moins mauvaise
possible dans cette situation même si
maintenant il faudra aussi reconstruire
l'économie chypriote sur un autre modèle
enfin la russie à laquelle vous êtes
attachés sur laquelle vous travaillez de
manière remarquable monsieur le sénateur
jean-pierre chevènement
la russie a été associé au processus le
ministre chypriote a passé plusieurs
jours en russie
et finalement les russes ont considéré
qu'il revenait aux européens de régler
cette situation mais nous devrons bien
sûr dialoguer pour l'avenir de l'île
avec la russie qui est un grand
partenaire pour nous voilà les réponses
que je voulais vous apportez complète
donc un peu longue mais néanmoins votre
question mairie merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à monsieur premier
ministre jean pierre raffarin pour le
groupe ump
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
le monde titré hier armée amputé france
des classes et monsieur le premier
ministre
quel paradoxe ce serait d'engager
l'armée française au mali et en même
temps de créer les conditions
budgétaires de son démantèlement ce que
la france est aujourd'hui au sahel avec
courage et succès pourra-t-elle le faire
dans cinq ans en aura-t-elle les moyens
déjà avec les réformes de la
professionnalisation conduite par le
président chirac et de la
rationalisation budgétaire
l'armée a fortement contribué à
l'exigence de réformes de l'état
le ministère de la défense monsieur le
ministre le drian et sur le plan des
efforts budgétaires largement plus
vertueux que de nombreux autres
départements ministériels les arbitrages
présidentiels
quant au livre blanc et bientôt quant à
la loi de programmation militaire
2014-2019 sont toujours à
tendu à l'initiative du président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense nationale notre collègue jean
louis carrère un large consensus s'est
affirmé au sénat pour demander un
plancher des ressources consacrées à la
défense fixé 1 5% du pib' renoncer à
cette exigence reviendrait à renoncer à
notre souveraineté et à placer notre
sécurité sous le parapluie américain
pour de nombreux pays la croissance des
risques est parallèle à la croissance
des budgets militaires renoncer à cette
exigence reviendrait aussi à renoncer
aux grands programmes de notre industrie
de défense ce qui nous condamnerait à
une destruction d'emplois dont le pays
n'a pas besoin
monsieur le premier ministre où en est
le processus d'arbitrage quant à
l'avenir du budget de la défense
et pensez vous convaincre nos
partenaires européens que les pays qui
par leur défense participe à la sécurité
de l'union puissent sortir une part de
leurs investissements militaires du
calcul de leurs déficits budgétaires et
ainsi aménager la règle des 3%
souhaitons que dans l'avenir la presse
titre armé soutenu france défend tu
merci monsieur jean marc ayrault premier
ministre
merci monsieur le président du sénat
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le premier ministre jean pierre
raffarin
vous imaginez bien que si le président
de la république a pris la décision
d'engager nos forces au mali ce n'est
pas pour demain nous empêcher de
poursuivre cette capacité d'engagement
au nom de la france mais même au delà de
la france car nous savons bien que dans
cette intervention qui a été approuvé
par tous les pays de l'afrique de
l'ouest par la communauté internationale
dans le cadre du respect du droit
international
ces demies c'est une mission que nous
engageons non seulement pour défendre
l'intégrité du mali pour défendre la
liberté et l'autonomie des pays de
l'afrique de l'ouest mais c'est aussi
une lutte sans merci contre le
terrorisme qui permet de défendre à la
fois les intérêts de la france de
l'europe et même au delà puisque mais ce
message est compris bien au-delà de
l'europe
donc ce n'est pas ce que nous sommes
capables de faire aujourd'hui qui
devrait nous conduire à nous empêcher de
le faire demain et je conclurai si vous
voulez bien sur cet engagement dans
quelques instants
c'est pour ça que le président de la
république a engagé un travail qui est
celui de la mise à jour du livre blanc
sur la défense et sur l'a6 que de la
sécurité nationale c'est un travail
considérable d'un grand intérêt et ce
livre blanc sera adoptée mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs à la fin du mois
d'avril
mais je souhaite que le parlement puisse
en débattre
que ce soit ici au sénat ou à
l'assemblée nationale avant l'été
c'est en tout cas un engagement que je
prends devant vous c'est la moindre des
choses
ce livre blanc présentera les risques
les menaces auxquelles notre pays doit
faire face mais surtout analysera le
contexte géopolitique qui est le nôtre
et les types d'engagements auxquels nous
devons faire face
il est bien évident que nous devons
continuer à défendre l'intégrité
territoriale de la france
vous avez parlé de souveraineté c'est la
base même de la défense nationale mais
c'est aussi la prise en compte de
risques nouveaux qui sont de plus en
plus lié
les risques intérieurs les risques
extérieurs doivent être abordé de la
même façon en tout cas avec la
nécessaire cohérence si nous voulons
être efficaces
le président de la république l'a
exprimé à plusieurs reprises et je le
redis devant le sénat le modèle d'armée
qui découlera de ces travaux sera
conforme aux ambitions de la france en
europe et dans le monde
c'est à dire je les ai rappelés protéger
notre territoire et la population
française préserver nos forces de
dissuasion dans ses deux composantes et
assurer nos capacités d'intervention
seul ou avec nos alliés
ce modèle répondra également aux
nouveaux enjeux que nous devons faire
face notamment dans le domaine de la
cyber défense
nous avons d'importants progrès à faire
comme celui du renseignement comme celui
du transport stratégique
ce n'est pas bien sûr au moment nous
engageons nos forces
osant mali avec un professionnalisme et
un engagement que je veux à nouveau
saluer que nous allons baisser la garde
d'ailleurs je voudrais profiter de cet
instant pour remercier à nouveau tous
les groupes parlementaires de toutes les
sensibilités que j'ai reçu lundi avec le
ministre des affaires étrangères le
belize et d'un défense et ont empêché
représenter parce qu'il est très
important qu'en effet dans ces
circonstances la communauté nationale
proclame son rassemblement et son unité
ce que chacun fait dans le respect de
ces différences politiques
je tiens à nouveau à le faire devant
vous à vous saluer et remercier au nom
de la france mais aussi au nom de nos
soldats qui sont aujourd'hui engagés
dans une mission particulièrement
difficile et dangereuse après l'adoption
du livre blanc il y aura la loi de
programmation militaire
elle sera à cohérente avec le modèle
d'armée que je viens d'évoquer
elle préservera aussi et je comprends à
votre préoccupation je la partage
l'excellence de notre industrie de
défense dont chacun mesure la nécessité
stratégique et la contribution dynamisme
de notre économie
je vous le dis franchement j'ai parfois
été surpris et compris de titres de
journaux
cessons de nous faire peur avec des
scénarios catastrophes qui n'ont jamais
était sérieusement envisagée en tout cas
ni par le président de la république ni
par moi même ni ministre de la défense
alors vous évoquez un sujet complexe et
celui d intégration dans le calcul du
déficit de chaque pays des dépenses
militaires ne dis pas que c'est un faux
problème
je dis simplement que dans ces
circonstances ça serait comme une
certaine forme de face à li de facilité
en quelque sorte une échappatoire parra
propre à nos propres responsabilités en
tout cas là où vous mettez le doigt sur
une question qui est juste
c'est la question de la défense
européenne qui est ces dernières années
a pris trop de retard et qui doit être
sur la la table sur l'or de l'ordre du
jour de l'union européenne c'est
d'ailleurs un sujet qui a été évoquée
récemment par le président de la
république lors d'une rencontre qui a eu
lieu à varsovie
ne laissons pas cette question deux
côtés il n'est pas juste que seuls deux
grands pays la grande bretagne et la
france fait tant d'efforts pour la
défense pas seulement de leur pays mais
aussi au service de l'europe
l'autonomie stratégique dépend tout
autant de notre modèle d'armé mais aussi
de notre capacité à redresser nos
finances publiques et sur ce point vous
avez évoqué les efforts qui ont été
faits par la défense nationale nos
armées depuis plusieurs années et je le
tiens effectivement à le saluer mais cet
effort de redressement de nos finances
publiques doit se poursuivre et chaque
ministère
il prendra sa part en tout cas je vous
dirais franchement monsieur le premier
ministre jean pierre raffarin que je
suis parfois étonnés d'une certaine
forme d'injustice à l'égard du
gouvernement
quand on critique nos intentions sans
les connaître
alors que si on regarde la loi de
programmation militaire précédente à
peine votée elle a déjà été oublié donc
évitons les fausses querelles évitons
les excès ce qui m'importe aujourd'hui
c'est de bâtir le modèle d'armée de
demain cohérent avec le dresse le
redressement de notre pays et avec les
risques et les menaces auxquelles il
doit faire face
je veux que s'instaure sur ce sujet un
dialogue serein entre l'ensemble des
forces politiques du pays
je sais monsieur le premier ministre
jean pierre raffarin l'intérêt que vous
portez à ces questions et votre propos
vient de une nouvelle fois de le
rappeler mais je veux vous assurer que
nous partageons ce sujet la même
ambition comme je le dis à l'ensemble
des sénateurs est que la france est une
grande nation elle qu'elle continuera à
jouer son rôle
j'en prends ici l'engagement ce que la
france fait au mali
elle pourra le faire encore dans cinq
ans merci merci la parole à monsieur
vincent capo-canellas pour le groupe
udi cusset merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur prix ministre
la semaine dernière vous avez déclaré à
l'assemblée nationale
je sais où je vais vous le mesurer tous
les jours le pays doute
et pourtant la france a de formidables
atouts elle ne peut se résigner et ne
doit pas se résigner au déclin
la crise est réelle vous l'avez d'abord
nié en invoquant le rude coup tour à la
croissance vous l'avez ensuite
sous-estimé mais le sujet n'est pas tant
la ses effets se sont amplifiées avec la
récession qui menace le chômage à un
niveau historique
le pouvoir d'achat en baisse et vous ne
pouvait cette fois nié que vous êtes en
responsabilité depuis près de 11 mois
maintenant nous vous reprocheront
d'avoir tardé à en mesurer les effets
d'avoir pris des mesures contre
cycliques de n'avoir pas d'emblée dit
aux français qu'il fallait réformer que
ce serait dur mais que nous pourrions
nous en sortir oui nous pouvons nous en
sortir à condition d'admettre qu'il faut
refonder notre modèle de production
qu'il faut re négocier notre modèle
social car l'entreprise n'est pas
l'ennemi de l'emploi qu'il faut sortir
de nos lourdeur admettent le monde tel
qu'il est en remédiant à nos rigidité
ces trois champs refonder notre
production rénovées notre modèle social
en finir avec nos rigidité mériterait
d'être vos trois seules priorités
au lieu de cela vous nous avez habitués
à une curieuse valls qui pourrait se
résumer ainsi une chose et son contraire
vous rétablissez la retraite à 60 ans
puis vous prenez conscience qu'il faut
allonger la durée de cotisation vous
nier le problème du coût du travail
ensuite vous découvrez le manque de
compétitivité des entreprises vous
voulez favoriser le dialogue social mais
vous votez lan ici sociale qui encourage
la casse dans les entreprises vous
parlez simplification et vous rajoutez
une couche au millefeuille territorial
vous réduit drastiquement les dotations
aux collectivités et vous alors dit
c'est leur charge
avec la réforme des rhinos colère le
désespoir guette
il est là la révolte n'est pas loin on
le sent sourdement qui ne le perçoit
vous savez vous allez dites vous vous
avez le choix entre trois attitudes
implorer la croissance ou l'avait déjà
fait son succès continuez à dire que
vous avez mis en place des outils et
qu'ils ont porté leurs fruits
c'est sans doute la méthode coué devrais
je dire la méthode héros troisième
solution changer de politique et
proposer au pays un nouveau compromis
économique et sociale en faveur de
l'emploi
cette dernière est celle que nos voisins
ont déjà mises en oeuvre monsieur
précise ma question est simple allez
vous enfin vous engager sur la voie
d'une autre politique autour d'un vrai
compromis économique et social qui seule
permettra le pays de se redresser
je remercie monsieur pierre moscovici
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le sénateur capot cas là je
commencerai par là vous avez terminé par
un mot que j'aime bien et qui est le mot
redressement est en effet c'est vrai que
le premier ministre et le gouvernement
savent où ils vont que nous savons où
nous allons que le président de la
république rappellera ce soir le cap et
c'est précisément le cap du redressement
et vous savez redressement
je suppose qu'il y eût dégradation et je
serais si j'étais vous un peu plus
discret sur ce point car donner de
leçons quand on a laissé la france dans
l'état où vous et la majorité précédente
l'avait laissé et ce n'est pas une
ritournelle
c'est un boulet pour nous et le boulet
il est toujours là le boulet ce show les
600 milliards d'euros de plus que vous
avez laissé s'accumuler
le boulet ce sont les déficits publics
que nous sommes contraints de réduire
car il était encore en 2012 sur une
tendance nettement supérieure à 5% du
pib si nous n'étions pas intervenus
le boulet c'est la compétitivité que
vous avez laissé se dégrader en dix ans
et qui fait qu'en 2002 la france avait
un excédent du commerce extérieur
desquels se trouve avec 70 milliards
d'euros de déficit
le boulet ce sont les emplois
industriels que vous avez laissé partir
la désindustrialisation qui s'est
installée eh bien nous nous sommes au
travail
nous sommes aux responsabilités et c'est
vrai que le redressement du pays prend
du temps que ceux de redressement c'est
un pays un conte redressement qui doit
concerner les finances publiques nous y
employons en mettant en oeuvre un effort
structurel qu'aucun gouvernement n'a
fait avant nous nous y employons en
faisant en sorte de sauver la zone euro
qui était menacée dans son existence
quand nous sommes arrivés aux
responsabilités il ya eu un changement
de cap
nous le faisons en mettant en oeuvre un
pacte de compétitivité qui est d'une
importance sans précédent et qui
justement touche à certaines des
dimensions que vous évoquez bien sûr le
coût du travail que nous réduisons à
travers le crédit d'impôt compétitivité
emploi mais aussi la simplification qui
est fondamentale et vous savez que c'est
là de la part du président république
une idée extrêmement forte c'est ce que
nous faisons
lever les rigidités accélérer les choses
faire en sorte que ça aille vite et que
les entreprises puissent investir
embaucher le faire rapidement le faire
simplement c'est aussi l'objet même de
la banque publique d'investissement qui
est à leurs appuis je ne veux pas
poursuivre beaucoup plus longtemps
mais vous savez ce que nous sommes en
train de faire c'est justement de
redresser le pays j'aime ce mot à
nouveau parce que vous l'avez dégradé
nous savons nous allons y lit un cap ça
prend du temps sans doute mais les
résultats seront au rendez vous et je
reprends ici l'engagement qui a été pris
par le président de république
d'inverser enfin après 21 mois qui se
sont écoulés
la courbe du chômage dans ce pays d'ici
à la fin 2013
voilà monsieur le sénateur la réponse je
voulais vous apporter merci madame
frédérique espagnac pour le groupe
socialiste apparentés
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres messieurs mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre du travail de l'emploi et de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social quand beaucoup d'entre vous j'ai
été une nouvelle fois surprise
d'entendre jean françois copé président
autoproclamé de l'ump données
d'élections de gestion gouvernement et à
la majorité présidentielle on regarde la
réalité des chiffres de l'économie de
notre pays
je souhaiterais dire notamment à nos
collègues de l'opposition que quand on a
un bilan aussi catastrophique que celui
qu avec du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy
on évite de se poser en donneur de
leçons sans même faire l'inventaire de
sa propre action 22 mois consécutifs de
hausse du chômage cela devrait amener la
droite à plus de modération dans la
critique et de modestie dans le propos
en plus quand on sait que de nombreuses
fermetures de sites ont été
volontairement retardé pour ne pas nuire
à la campagne du président sortant
nicolas sarkozy comme l'a déclaré
monsieur fillon
on ne se pose pas en donneur de leçons
notre bilan mes chers collègues nous
l'assumerons le moment venu mais pour
l'instant nous travaillons
alors oui le gouvernement travaille au
redressement de nos comptes publics
oui le gouvernement travaille à la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
et oui le gouvernement travaille à la
sécurisation du marché du travail
aujourd'hui le président de la
république françois hollande est
derrière lui les parlementaires de la
majorité se sont engagés à inverser la
courbe du chômage d'ici la fin de
l'année 2013
messieurs les ministres cent mille
emplois de l'avenir à l'attention des
jeunes les plus éloignés de l'emploi
cinq cent mille emplois de génération à
l'attention des jeunes et des seniors
le crédit impôt compétitivité emploi le
crédit impôt recherche à l'attention
notamment des pme et des tpe
monsieur le ministre vous pouvez vous
détailler plus encore à la tension de la
représentation nationale et des français
qui nous regarde l'action que le
gouvernement a et va continuer à mettre
en place pour le compte de lutter contre
ce fléau que représente le chômage je
vous remercie
merci la parole à monsieur michel
sapeurs ministre du travail de l'emploi
de la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
vous soulignez il n'est pas besoin
d'ailleurs de hausser la voix ni sur
aucun de ces bancs la continuité dans la
hausse du chômage depuis des mois depuis
des années vous disiez vous même
vingt-deux mois de hausse
puis-je me permettent de vous corriger
cinquante sept mois de hausse
la vérité la réalité des choses et c'est
d'ailleurs la gravité de la situation
pour nous tous c'est qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'un chômage qui aurait augmenté au
cours de ces derniers mois
suite était grave mais pas trop c'est un
chômage qui augmente depuis mai 2008
depuis mai 2008 sauf un mois chaque mois
chaque ministre du travail et de
l'emploi a annoncé une hausse du nombre
des chômeurs ce qui veut dire quoi
ce qui veut dire que au delà du chiffre
on peut dire qu'il ya tel ou tel record
quel beau record au delà du chiffre
ce sont des jeunes beaucoup plus
nombreux qu'autrefois qui se trouve
aujourd'hui sans emploi est trop souvent
sans formation ce sont des plus âgés qui
plus nombreux qu'autrefois se trouve
poussé en dehors de l'entreprise et qui
ont du mal à retrouver un emploi
messieurs les sénateurs car ce sont
plutôt des voies mal que j'entends à
l'instant vous devriez sur ce sujet
comme sur beaucoup d'autres avoir la
modestie de ce qui regarde la vérité en
face et la vérité c'est celle que je
viens de décrire
cinquante sept mois de hausse du chômage
donc inutile d'en faire le commentaire
plus haut qu'il ne convient il faut agir
agir pour les jeunes sans emploi sans
formation
cent cinquante mille emplois d'avenir ce
texte de loi a été votée ici largement
sur ces bancs agir pour les jeunes sans
emploi sans formation parce que ceux qui
sont le plus éloignés
il faut leur offrir l'opportunité d'un
emploi mais surtout cette formation qui
le bagage personnel de chacun le contrat
de génération et se fait de dire des
sceaux bredouille des choses saugrenues
comme vous venez de dire le contrat de
génération il a été voté ici très
largement sur ces bancs y compris au
sein de vos propres quand il a été voté
et si vous voulez des noms je vais les
donner et heureusement il ya des gens
intelligents partout pour apporter
concrètement des solutions aux plus
jeunes pour qu'ils trouvent un emploi
aux plus âgés pour qu'il puisse nous
éviter de sortir de l'emploi et puis
pour l'emploi à qui nous avons accordé
deux mille emplois supplémentaires 4000
emplois en moins d'un an
là où d'autres avaient supprimer 2000
emplois alors que le chômage lui-même
explosait c'est ainsi par des
dispositifs législatifs par des actions
concrètes par un accompagnement
personnalisé des chômeurs que nous
pourrons enfin mettre fin à cette montée
qui était jusqu'à lors inexorable du
chômage
merci la parole à monsieur pierre charon
pour le groupe ump
ce président nommé messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre
dimanche 24 mars dernier les opposants à
la loi dite de mariage pour tous se sont
à nouveau réunis pour une manifestation
familiale et pacifique
une fois de plus vos services ont
annoncé des chiffres de participation
aberrant confirmé encore hier soir à 300
milles qui démontre une volonté
délibérée de mentir aux français afin de
minimiser la réalité de ce mouvement de
contestation
énorme mouvement de contestation vous
avez ainsi égaré le 13 janvier sept cent
mille manifestants et plus d'un million
cette fois ci je conçois que le
gouvernement soit agacé par la
détermination et la mobilisation massive
des opposants à ce texte
mais cet agacement ne serait ni
justifier la manipulation grossière des
chiffres ni les instructions données par
vous même de la salle de commandement de
la pp assisté du préfet de police
comment expliquez-vous l'utilisation de
ce que vous appelez les aérosols sont
les femmes les pères de famille et les
enfants jusqu'à présent les airs au sol
sert plus pour les asthmatiques que pour
les manifestants pourquoi pas des
vaporisateurs non plus alors qu'il
s'agit de lacrymogènes disons les mots
n'ayez pas peur des mots vous savez
parler de groupes extrémistes hier
encore à l'assemblée nationale fortement
secoué par mes collègues députés
mais monsieur le ministre je ne sais pas
si quelques agités ont pu se faufiler
dans la foule
mais toutes les images et les vidéos
sont accablantes pour vous et vos
services aux extrémistes sont des
fillettes de 8 ans des personnes âgées
des bonnes soeurs des familles
nombreuses et des élus de la république
rendez public les nombreuses plaintes de
journaliste contre vos services qui ont
été déposés à l'atp
d'ailleurs à l'heure où je vous parle un
enfant de 14 ans est toujours
hospitalisée ne sachant pas s'il
récupère à l'usagé d'un oeil
monsieur le ministre quand pouvoir s'en
prend aux enfants c'est la république
qui saigne comment pouvez vous expliquer
aux français qu'une semaine plus tôt les
crs étaient restés impassibles devant
les syndicats pessah qui faisait brûler
des pneus sur cette même avenue de la
grande armée
comment pouvez vous affirmer que les
organisateurs ont été débordés par la
manifestation pardon ce sont vos
services de renseignements qu'ils
avaient encore prévoyez cent mille
personnes au doigt mouillé
effectivement si vous attendiez 15 fois
moins de manifestants il n'est pas
anormal que vous servir cet été débordé
et que l'on déplore ces incidents c'est
une responsabilité du préfet de police
de paris
monsieur boucau d'avoir figé et
manifestants sans prévoir d'ici au
cortège vous savez ce que c'est ça
revient à peu près à remplir une boîte
de nuit sans senti de secours cela dit
quand on nomme un directeur de l'ena
patron du maintien de l'ordre et que
l'on court entre les fauteuils du grand
rex et la salle de commandement de la pp
il faut pas s'étonner que ça déborde
c'est pourquoi monsieur le ministre
devant l'absence de vrai qu il faut
terminer nous avons décidé avec un
certain nombre de collègues sénateurs de
demander l'ouverture d'une commission
d'enquêté afin qu'elles éclaircissent
les conditions dans laquelle la prairie
sur n'a pas anticipé n'a pas encadrées
et a menti aux français sur la
participation
merci la parole est à monsieur manuel
valls ministre de l'intérieur c'est le
président monsieur le sénateur et que
cherchez vous monsieur charon à remettre
en cause la parole de l'état celle du
préfet de police a contesté par ailleurs
la légitimité du parlement celles des
représentants de la nation vous allez
être saisie d'un texte celui du mariage
pour tous ceux dans quelques jours qui
ont majoritairement adopté à l'assemblée
nationale le projet de loi à l'assemblée
nationale
vous avez gouverner vous avez assumé les
responsabilités vos amis pas vous et
après ce que j'ai entendu heureusement
monsieur charon vous avez été confronté
à des mouvements sociaux la nécessité du
maintien de l'ordre à la colère aussi
des français et là vous venez donner des
leçons ici
monsieur charon vous qui avez souvent
fréquenté vous qui avez souvent
fréquenté la préfecture de police
vous savez parfaitement que la méthode
de comptage est la même pour tous les
rassemblements et toutes les
manifestations là même qui est utilisé
depuis des années et le chiffre de 300
milles qui peut penser et le chiffre de
300 milles est déjà très important mais
qui peut penser que dans paris il y
avait dimanche dernier plus d'un million
de manifestants
enfin ça n'a aucun sens et pourquoi pas
2 millions et pourquoi 3 millions vous
essayez le tromper les français sur ce
sujet là et ce chiffre de 300 milles
vient d'être démontrée et derrière vos
accusations
il y à des professionnels des
fonctionnaires consciencieux il y avait
2000 policiers et gendarmes dimanche
dernier 2000 et s'était adapté aux
chiffres que nous avions parce que nous
savions qu'il y avait à peu près le même
nombre non ne croyez pas vos aux
officines
vous avez trop fréquentes et monsieur
charon vous avez trop fréquenter les
officines de la république et vous savez
bien le poids et ceci est derrière est
la preuve
et d'ailleurs je les tiens vaut
disposition les photographies de la
manifestation ont été publiés hier et
vous le savez sur le site de la
préfecture de police parce que nous
n'avons rien à cacher les manifestants a
annoncé un chiffre mais quel mode de
comptage ont-ils utilisé
vous pensez pouvoir confirmer sa
fiabilité c'était peut-être l'une de vos
rares manifestations
à moins que vous y ait participé à
d'autres manifestations il ya quelques
années
vous voyez cette polémique n'a pas lieu
d'être
les débordements qui ont eu lieu alors
même que les consignes de la préfecture
étaient claires sont inacceptables et
quand on se réclame souvent sur d'autres
sujets du parti de l'ordre
il est bien étonnant de voir ici un
parlementaire saluer ceux qui s'en
prennent aux forces de l'ordre
il ya eu il y a eu de nombreux appels
répétés sur internet et sur les réseaux
sociaux pour braver une décision
préfectorale pour braver une décision
préfectorale confirmés et je vous le
rappel par le tribunal administratif de
paris
enfin les organisateurs ne pouvaient
ignorer et vous ne pouvez pas l'ignorer
et là aussi les photos les images les
médias l'ont montré le rôle des
extrémistes du bloc identitaire je le
rappelle des jeunesses nationalistes du
renouveau français du gud d'europe
jeunesse qui étaient sur place et qui
brandissaient leurs bras devant les
forces de l'ordre et saout si monsieur
charon vous l'excusé et vous trouvez
normal que vos à parlementaire accepté
payer les sommes qu'ils soient mis en
cause les forces de l'ordre sont
intervenues et moi je suis cohérent il
ne peut pas y avoir dans une démocratie
le moindre débordement et les forces de
l'ordre
le préfet de police et vous n'avez pas
le droit ici au sénat à l'assemblée de
mettre en cause un homme d'état quel le
préfet bernard boucault c'est
inacceptable c'est d'une lâcheté
inacceptable merci monsieur ministre est
pas
merci la parole et à monsieur michel
berson pour le bourg socialiste le seul
président mes chers collègues ou ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
après le projet de loi dont le parlement
vient d'être saisi notre système
d'enseignement supérieur et de recherche
va enfin être placé au coeur du
redressement de notre pays et au service
de la compétitivité et de la croissance
l'état va enfin redevenir stratège nous
sommes en crise
oui nous sommes en crise mais la france
est un grand pays et là des atouts et la
de réelle capacité à inventer à innover
notre recherche fondamentale est
mondialement reconnue notre recherche
publique atteint un niveau d'excellence
les prix nobel et les médailles fields
la teste
mais nos entreprises privées réalise un
effort de recherche notoirement
insuffisant comme l'a souligné le
rapport gallois notre industrie souffre
d'un manque d'innovation les pme
innovantes issues notamment de la
recherche publique ne sont pas
efficacement soutenues la recherche
technologique et les transferts sont
notre point faible
force est de constater aujourd'hui que
la stratégie nationale de recherche et
d'innovation lancé en 2006 2007 a été un
échec
ces priorités n'ont pas été clairement
défini sa mise en oeuvre n'a pas
bénéficié d'un réel suivi après avoir
subi une rafale de réformes brouillonne
le système français de recherche et
d'innovation est devenu il
visible en termes d'organisation comme
en termes de gouvernance
madame le ministre comment le
gouvernement entend qu'il remette de
l'ordre dans la gouvernance de notre
système de recherche et d'innovation
tant au niveau national que
territoriales comment ont-ils favoriser
les transferts de technologie vers
l'industrie vers la société pour créer
de nouvelles activités donc des emplois
notamment dans les filières d'avenir
comment le gouvernement entend t-il
organisé de réelle coopération entre les
universités les grandes écoles et les
organismes de recherche renforcer lés
partenariats entre le monde parte
économique et académique pour que la
france soit enfin à la hauteur des
grands défis technologiques et sociétaux
auquel elle doit aujourd'hui répondre
merci madame geneviève fioraso ministres
enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur michel berson alors dynamiser
notre recherche vous l'avez dit c'est un
objectif qui est prioritaire dans le
projet de loi sur l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche qui sera
débattu au parlement à partir du 13 mai
prochain avec la priorité accordée à la
réussite étudiante parce que le niveau
l'élévation du niveau de qualification
est une urgence dans notre pays
cette nouvelle ambition pour la
recherche prend une place essentielle
dans le redressement de notre pays avec
la compétitivité par la qualité la seule
qui soit durable
c'est ce que font d'ailleurs la plupart
des pays émergents et des pays
développés et nous avons de ce point de
vue au cours des dix dernières années
pris beaucoup de retard
avec 2,2 pour cent de notre pib
dédié à la recherche et au développement
une part trop faible vous l'avez dit de
la recherche privée
nous sommes bien loin des objectifs de
lisbonne qui était fixé à 3%
bien loin de nos voisins loups allemands
qui ont atteint 3 % et encore plus loin
de la république de corée qu'il ya 50
ans était un pays ruiné qu'aujourd'hui
consacre 4 3%
de son pib à la recherche et au
développement c'est dire la nature du
rebond qu'il nous faut faire et c'est
toi donnera les outils les moyens et
l'environnement de ce rebond
indispensable alors oui l'état stratège
est de retour il n'y avait plus de
stratégie de recherche dans ce pays
chaque agence de son côté élaboré sa
petite stratégie personnelle sans qu'il
n'y ait la moindre coordination et la
moindre visibilité
alors oui nous pouvons être fiers de
notre recherche fondamentale de nos
médailles fields de nos prix nobel de
nos prix poincaré elle est unanimement
reconnue dans le monde mais notre
recherche technologique le transfert le
lien le décloisonnement entre la
recherche fondamentale et le milieu
économique sans définitivement nos
points faibles
c'est cela que la loi se propose
d'améliorer avec des dispositifs de
transfert beaucoup plus efficace la
mission même de transfert inscrits pour
la première fois dans les missions de
service public de nos chercheurs un
objectif d'élévation du niveau de
formation de notre jeunesse à 50% alors
que nous sommes à 43% bien loin là
encore des objectifs de bologne qui
était à 50 % il ya une dizaine d'années
nous allons préserver notre recherche
fondamentale de la précarité à laquelle
elle est confrontée en lui redonnant des
crédits récurrents et nous allons lancer
des appels à projets et un agenda
stratégique en nous appuyant sur un
conseil d'expert et qui répondront aux
enjeux sociétaux que vous avez signalé
monsieur le sénateur et qui sont
importants
ces gens je sociétaux seront ceux de
l'europe pour être plus fort plus fort
sur le plan national plus fort sur le
plan européen
et c'est ainsi mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que nous allons pleinement
contribué à la construction d'un projet
de société basé sur la connaissance sur
l'innovation sur la croyance dans
l'avenir c'est pourquoi dans quelques
minutes
je vais libérer les chercheurs en
biologie les chercheurs en médecine de
cette contrainte que vous fait peser sur
eux avec l'interdiction d'opérer des
recherches sur les cellules souches
embryonnaires
je vous remercie de votre ado merci la
parole à monsieur jean françois humbert
pour le groupe e
mp le seul président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur michel sapin monsieur le
ministre
qui peut encore croire à la promesse
l'affirmé cette semaine par françois
hollande d'inverser la courbe du chômage
d'ici à la fin de l'année personne nous
le verrons bien ce soir d'ailleurs 68%
des français sont inquiets de leur
avenir ils peuvent l'être avec un
pouvoir d'achat en baisse de 0 8% au
quatrième trimestre de 2012 et de 0 4%
sur l'année 2012 selon l'insee premier
recul depuis 1984 presse principalement
en raison de fonctions sociales et
fiscales inégales et ce sont les
économistes qui le disent
la france souffre les français souffrent
mais labs et messieurs les ministres
l'appel à la mobilisation générale pour
l'emploi du premier ministre lancé il y
a peu quand plus de 2 260 mille chômeurs
supplémentaires ont été enregistrées en
neuf mois soit un tiers environ de la
hausse enregistrée sur les cinq années
précédentes
cet appel prend des allures pathétiques
c'était il y a neuf fois qu'il fallait
agir comme le président hollande s'y
était engagé durant sa campagne
au lieu de cela vous avez multiplié les
réformes dit sociétale à l'ecoute de
minorités proposer des réformes de
convenance plus tactique qu'autre chose
ce ne sont pas 150 mille emplois
d'avenir concrétiser jusqu'à présent et
le contrat de génération qui peuvent
constituer une politique face au fléau
du chômage bien plus plus vous avez
envoyé des signaux très concrets de
défiance envers les entreprises dès le
départ provoqué un véritable choc fiscal
alors que c'est là dans les entreprises
que se créent la richesse de demain
c'est d'elle que viendra la croissance
comme on l'espérait d'ailleurs cette
croissance quand un excès de normes rend
les entreprises françaises toujours plus
vulnérables dans le jeu de la
concurrence mondiale
certainement pas les mesures du plan
compétitivité emploi
arrêtez moi une véritable usine à gaz
monsieur le ministre
quand allez vous conduire une réelle
politique de l'emploi quand ce
gouvernement va-t-il enfin mettre de la
cohérence dans sa politique
quand allez vous arrêter de dresser les
français les uns contre les autres
que comptez vous faire pour redonner de
la confiance à ce pays
et en ce pays merci merci monsieur
michel sapin minuscule travail merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
merci monsieur le sénateur pour cette
question pleine d'ambition sur le retour
de la confiance la confiance qui a
disparu depuis de si nombreuses années
dans ce pays
je me souviens de quelqu'un vous
trouverez le nom qui disait à peine élu
je vais aller chercher la croissance
avec les dents
quelle a été la croissance au cours des
cinq dernières années 00 croissance en
cinq ans pas étonnant qu alors le nombre
des chômeurs pendant les mêmes cinq
années est augmenté de plus de 1 million
je comprends totalement
c'est parfaitement dans votre rôle d'élu
parfaitement dans votre rôle d'élu et
vous le dites avec une modération dont
votre voisin immédiat devrait à
l'instant pouvoir s'inspirer
il est tout à fait dans votre rôle d'élu
de poser des questions sur ce sur le
chômage sur l'emploi mais faites-le s'il
vous plaît vous qui avez été
responsables de grandes collectivités
territoriales comme d'autres ici faites
le avec la modestie de ceux qui n'ont
pas réussi qui n'ont pas réussi qui ont
échoué et qui à partir de là sont
parfaitement légitimes pour donner des
conseils mais doivent le faire avec la
retenue qui convient dans ces cas là
monsieur le sénateur quel est le sens
quelle est la cohérence c'est l'action
ce sont des outils vous pouvez vouloir
tourner en dérision tel outil
les emplois d'avenir cent cinquante
mille
demandez-lui de s'inspirer de votre
modération à votre voisin je pense que
le sénat tout entier en sera honorée
donc monsieur le sénateur cent cinquante
mille emplois d'avenir
ils vont être mis en oeuvre sans me
d'ici la fin de cette année les
collectivités territoriales y compris de
votre département du doubs de votre
région vont faire en sorte qu'il y ait
des emplois d'avenir c'est autant de
solutions concrètes pour des jeunes qui
aujourd'hui n'ont aucune possibilité
d'emploi et n'ont aucune possibilité de
formation c'est concret c'est simple
mais il faut le mettre en
il faut se mobiliser les uns et les
autres vous disiez à juste titre
monsieur le sénateur réunissons-nous
dans cette bataille pour l'emploi
agissons tous ensemble même si ici il a
pu y avoir des débats assez normal en
démocratie pour ou contre tel outil mais
les emplois d'avenir c'est utile
agissons ensemble
le contrat de génération vous ne
demander des comptes c'est normal de la
part de la représentation nationale de
demander des comptes
le contrat de génération il est en
application depuis lundi dernier
demandons des comptes mais y en a déjà
qui sont signés et ça ça marche vous le
savez les employeurs les entreprises les
pme les pmi les artisans et les
commerçants de votre région ils sont en
train de s'emparer de ce très bel outil
extrêmement efficace pour les jeunes
comme pour les plus anciens oui monsieur
le sénateur
réunissons-nous autour de cette bataille
qui est de l'intérêt de la france et de
chacun des français
la lutte contre le chômage et nous
atteindrons ainsi ensemble l'objectif
que nous nous sommes fixés un verset
enfin la courbe du chômage
merci monsieur pierre bernard et mans
pour la réunion administrative des
sénateurs de figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe
monsieur le président ma question
s'adressait à monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères madame la ministre
chargé des français de l'étranger
je vais vous parler de l'europe à 1h
certes un peu tardive et je m'en excuse
bien que je n'en sois pas responsable
auprès des collègues qui m'ont fait
l'amitié de rester dans cet hémicycle
c'est au milieu de l'hiver au moment où
chacun est légitimement très sensible à
la détresse des sans domicile fixe que
l'europe annonce la baisse de ces
crédits des aides alimentaires alors que
beaucoup de parents ne connaissent
l'europe qu'à travers le programme
erasmus qui permet à leurs enfants de
poursuivre des études à l'étranger
c'est ce programme que l'on annonce en
diminution
c'est au lendemain du scandale de la
viande de cheval que l'europe autorise à
nouveau les farines animales
durant toute la crise financière le
maître mot qui a été à la base de toutes
les politiques et le mot confiance
confiance entre les états par une
surveillance mutuelle renforcée
confiance entre les banques en raison de
leurs emprunts toxiques confiance entre
les banques et leurs déposants et voilà
que la sphère chypriote vient ébranler
cette confiance dans l'europe entière
alors que la plupart des chefs d'état
doivent juguler d'énormes dettes au
niveau national et que la relance
indispensable aurait pu se faire au
niveau de l'europe qui elle n'est pas
endetté c'est le moment choisi par les
chefs d'état faute de ressources propres
au budget européen pour réduire ses
budgets européens des sept prochaines
années a à peine 1% du revenu brut
européen les institutions européennes
ont elles décidé de faire le jeu du
populisme du nationalisme et du
séparatisme
madame la ministre de tels faits ne
doivent-ils pas inciter la france à
proposer l'année prochaine après les
élections au parlement européen une
nouvelle réforme institutionnelle
redessinant avec ceux qui le veulent un
vrai projet à long terme pour l'europe
instaurant notamment un pouvoir plus
intégré merci madame hélène conway
mouret ministre chargé des français de
l'étranger
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur thierry repentin ministre des
affaires européennes vous prie de
l'excuser il est en ce moment à
l'assemblée nationale et je répondrai à
votre question sommes conscients que
l'union européenne traverse aujourd'hui
la plus grave crise économique de son
histoire
cette crise les institutions européennes
comme les états membres et ont apporté
des réponses parfois inadaptés d'autres
fois trop tardive
face à ces difficultés le président de
la république a engagé dès son arrivée
aux responsabilités
la réorientation de la construction
européenne par la croissance et l'emploi
cette réorientation nous la mettons en
oeuvre résolument depuis dix mois et
depuis 10 mois nous avons obtenu des
avancées importantes sur la croissance
d'abord la banque
l'accord du conseil européen de juin sur
le pacte pour la croissance et l'emploi
de 120 milliards
le brevet unitaire européen qui
représente une victoire historique
après plusieurs décennies de
négociations sur la régulation de la
finance des mesures immédiates
déstabilisation la taxe sur les
transactions financières que nous avons
obtenus grâce à un accord franco
allemand la supervision bancaire prélude
à une véritable union bancaire de la
zone euro
vous évoquez aussi le programme erasmus
dont vous vantez a raison l'immense
succès contrairement à certaines
déclarations alarmistes
je rappelle ici que la pérennité de ce
programme n'est pas menacée
le montant qui lui est allouée au titre
du prochain cadre financier pluriannuel
de l'union devrait en outre augmenter en
termes réels
vous soulevez ensuite la question des
farines animales
si je vous conseille d'une certaine
maladresse de communication de la part
de la commission
je rappelle que cette décision à
laquelle la france s'était d'ailleurs
opposé n'entraîne aucun risque sanitaire
s'agissant du programme européen d'aidé
aux plus démunis
la précédente majorité avait cru bon de
le condamner nous l'avons sauver c'est
pas son niveau antérieur de 3.5
milliards
mais au niveau proposé par la commission
c'est à dire 2,5 milliards d'euros
en ce qui concerne le budget de l'union
nous l'aurions en effet souhaité plus
ambitieux c'est néanmoins un compromis
qui préserve nos outils le croissance
les conditions énoncées par le parlement
européen qui reprennent par ailleurs des
demandes françaises devraient nous
permettre d'améliorer ce compromis dans
et déjà de grands chantiers européens
ont été lancés l'approfondissement de
l'union économique et monétaire
le développement d'une politique
industrielle plus intégré le juste
échange dans les relations commerciales
notamment doivent renforcer l'union
européenne dans la mondialisation et
protéger ses peuples
voilà le chemin que nous traçons pour
l'europe de demain
merci mes chers collègues nous en avons
fini avec des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise dans quelques instants pour
l'examen de la proposition de loi visant
à l'abrogation du mal à vous venez de
suivre en direct les questions
d'actualité au sénat
tout de suite nous nous allons refaire
la séance
bienvenue sur public sénat on va refaire
la séance dans un instant avec nos
invités bien évidemment il ya une petite
passe d'armes dans l'hémicycle tout à
l'heure lors des questions d'actualité
entre le ministre de l'intérieur manuel
valls et pierre chareau sénateurs qui va
nous rejoindre sur ce plateau notamment
sur la question du comptage des
manifestants lors des manifestations